cnn's chris cuomo went ballistic after
being confronted by a heckler while he
was out with his family
cuomo losing it when the guy apparently
called him fredo
a reference from the movie the godfather
check out this heated confrontation
has since responded saying he uh
misspoke no he said he should have acted
better and not taken the bait but his
interpretation of the word fredo
has apparently changed over the years
here's what he said back in 2010
there is a there is a group of people of
politicos who always hint that they
might run but don't necessarily plunge
all the way
and they are members of la cuomo nostra
so who am i then and cnn
is creating even more controversy for
its response claiming that fredo
is a quote ethnic slur apparently the
network forgot to check all the times
the media have said it including on
cuomo's very own show
daddy kept fredo back home so
who cares what donald trump jr says
devin nunes is proving himself again and
again to be the fredo of the republican
party
this guy on these different occasions
basically tried to obstruct justice fact
that he was saying
nobody respected him enough to carry out
his orders oh and of course
fredo
you know uh greg we should all just uh
enjoy this story what i especially like
about it is when he goes
straight to that blizzard of f words yes
he actually says
oh by the way i'm chris cuomo i have a
show on cnn
uh because unless you're stuck at the
airport at gate 27 like jesse
you wouldn't have no idea who he is so
he actually identified himself
in the midst of the blizzard there are
two don'ts in this story number one
you don't want to bother people when
they're out in public it's not a nice
thing
but also don't turn things that aren't
racist into some things that are
which is cnn's profit model you know
fredo is not the
n word and that should be insulting to
any black person he owes an apology to
and nor is fake news the n word for
journalism which is
something in in cuomo's brain that he
keeps saying well that's the n word for
fake news that's the n word for italians
it's something that he uses over and
over good
analogy it's an analogy for his own
claims of victimhood
which is it just rubs me the wrong way
and remember this is the guy who
defended antifa
the guy that went after him is nothing
like anti-foss so i don't know why he
would get that pissed off
about that guy and not give it you know
and give some kind of
shelter for antifa but bottom line is uh
you know i think he knew this was
happening and i think this feeds into
his um
i don't know his reputation as a tough
guy so this is okay and also
he works for a network that throws
around the h
word hitler everybody that works here
is somehow at white supremacists
according to cnn
so screw them all sorry so so
if i follow that don't worry don't worry
i i'm trying i the the victimhood thing
is the most absurd bit about this uh
jedidiah that the idea that alfredo it
is
it's like a dog whistle and so the
poodle reacted
yeah i mean it's not i'm italian it's
not the equivalent of the n-word in
italian it's not an ethnic slur it's not
nice i mean you're basically calling
someone a loser
uh you know an idiot a screw-up it's
kind of that feel to it so it's not nice
i do get though i mean he's out with his
family
yeah and he's trying to have a decent
time he's trying to have decent these
people that now exist
to incite you to come up to you to
aggravate you
to disrupt your peace to record you to
try to capture
some crazy thing that you've said that
they can then distribute on the internet
it it can be infuriating and i you know
i have my own moments where i could be
out and that could happen and i might
start just you know blown off steam in
that moment so i get it
i get it i get it he came out and he
said i shouldn't have reacted that way i
shouldn't have taken the bait we can all
say that but
i do i do get the frustration of just
existing in the public
eye in this day and age and this is this
is the new normal like oh you go out
you're gonna get you're in the public
eye you
you're opening yourself up to harassment
there's got to be some space where like
don't go out alone
leave me alone you know don't go out
there there's
normal situations that go off the rails
if you're eating and some guy wants to
get in your face in a restaurant i'm
sure you've
you've had that one um but you don't
do what this guy did there's a cool way
to uh react to this kind of thing isn't
there
there is i tend to walk away uh but it
happens
and it's very unpleasant now i must say
i'm taken by the idea that this was
recorded
it indicates to me this was a setup of
chris cuomo
and i think that the kind of
rhetoric the guy was using was intended
to provoke chris cuomo
and i think that's why you see so many
people standing up for quiz cuomo
including people on this channel
i see the president doesn't like he says
the right is always being suckering why
are we defending chris cuomo well i
don't think that i think that what it is
is that
you know i mean i just wrote about in my
column this week you know that i was
after we did a show in dallas some guy
comes up to me he starts using
the offensive word right uh and says he
likes trolling me and he and his buddies
like
putting me down and i'm like you know
what am i to do with this guy and then
he asked for a selfie
i mean it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable did you
did you give him this house you know
because i don't want it's like
this you asked me what do i do do you
think the comparison is fair
do you think the comparison is fair that
fredo is the n word
that's crazy yeah but that's not the
point the point to me is
this guy set up chris cuomo chris cuomo
fell for the debate
and because i think all of us know that
there are moments i mean you know
i i i apparently i'm very recognizable
so i get a lot
you know what i would uh love to see i
would love to see someone come
up to dana parino in a restaurant and
for dana to launch into
a lizard of f words i don't care if it's
a set
up someone should set that up i am so
unrecognizable like
like this doesn't happen relatively like
like when you're outside of new york
might see you i've not had a situation
like that years ago i remember being
called a war criminal
at uh at the airport i apologize for
that and i called security
but here's my um two things on this is
that one i find it very unattractive
when men do this
like super unattractive um i also feel
like
having been the white house press
secretary right you you
never ever let them rattle you do not
let them rob you of your dignity
um but also you have to remember the
cameras are always on always now right
so
there's there's that the other thing is
i have
i'm at a total loss i don't understand
this controversy because i never saw the
godfather
right now that's
i was walking down the street with don
rumsfeld after lunch at the time of the
iraq war
and there's all these code pink people
and he they're all going war criminal
war criminal war
and he just goes hey hi great to see you
you know what happens sometimes with me
they don't know about my wife
she doesn't play by the same rules